I learned a lot from Sicario and uh
watching Benicio del Toro dude that one
set and then watching the film and I was
like this guy is a magician no because
he's doing nothing he's actually doing
nothing well you feel everything and I
watched it it's why I was like this is I
don't know and so I kind of was like oh
it's the audacity to do nothing I
suppose I know it's very similar to
Chris and get out you we as a viewer
everything you lead us to the point
we're always unfolding at the same time
you're unfolding is in each piece is
coming together okay we're not fed that
in advance in a really clever way kind
of it's all seen through you and every
time something is real you know you know
oh and so you know even kind of a bit
were the keys and you just see or you've
got a realization how did you work with
Jordan to keep that tension so it was a
real great level of tension all the way
through that you know it could have been
lost at any time but it's just so
balanced how did you keep the the
thriller for the audience as well as
yourself I mean that's like cool I
learned a lot that's implicit in a lot
from Sicario and uh watching Benicio del
Toro dude that one set and then watching
the film and I was like this guy is a
magician not because he's doing nothing
he's actually doing nothing oh you feel
everything and I watched it that's why I
was like this is I don't know and so I
kind of was like oh it's the audacity to
do nothing you know is and a new
basically allow the audience to project
and but that's what truly happens in
those experiences that's the their
conflict you're going for you guys I
know you're being kind of disrespectful
I can't I can't say that right now and I
have to choose when I say that but I
still feel that and so that was in the
script that's what I'm saying where
Jordan did the work in terms of the
write and dynamics is about having to
navigate that and also on top of all of
it he's trying to be a good boyfriend so
there's that kind of like but you know I
think everyone subconsciously knows if
you're going through that experience
there needs to be released in some way
so a lot of times I think people stay
for the release and it's just that you
wanna see said you don't want to
indicate you don't want to show like ah
you just want to go all right cool like
that you just want to be real that's
what would happen in real situation that
allowed the audience in to what this guy
is thinking and then they follow and
they and they come to their own
conclusions which may be what you're
doing it may not be what you're doing
but that's the interesting bit you know
he's like just let what do you think you
know the training ground you've both had
in a way it kind of us just looking
through the list of directors that
you've both already work with in the
sense with Greta Gerwig and Luca and
with den evil nerve with Jordan Peele
and I think you've just completed
something as Steve McQueen as well do
you feel that you perhaps like you know
I kind of you've just very fortunate in
that sense that you know you've had this
incredible training ground with these
four masters of cinema already what are
the key things that you've learned along
the way from each of them yeah I like I
really like how you put that because I
like I left college to pursue acting and
that was one of my big insecurities was
I don't want to meet myself six years
from now and feel like I was dumber
opinion there hadn't been challenged and
I think it can be easy to be cynical or
jaded about show business and think Oh
to do it at a young age you know the
roadmap is is maybe not unhealthy but I
mean like every like you put it like
every set is learning experience and
what's been thrilling is for me is
working with the directors that are as
instinctual as actors and that see
framing and cameras like as an instinct
and the way it's it's totally foreign to
me the way I feel about acting and like
I had a small part in interstellar but I
got to see Christopher Nolan work for
ten days and it's all instinct it's all
like he knows eeks I don't I didn't see
him like think something through once it
was like nope there there there boom
boom boom boom boom boom look like he
knew exactly we wanted so that was he
but if it up like even it wanted to
Steve I'd like the first day on set was
this massive scene like I look like I'm
being an accent and it was like this big
scene I had to do like I'm really the
one I did the audition at to doing this
like I really I can't say what happens
in it but but it was yeah and I kind of
spoke to him about onset cuz I was
I was nervous I was nervous and then
because I really respect him and then
and it was just that thing when I think
what you communicate is something that
they all kind of believed in he was like
like he's like I set the boundaries do
what you want
within that you mean and in it's like
and then it's like surprised me surprise
yourself and that's what the spontaneity
was talking about it's like what happens
in a moment that's the exciting bit
because you can't actually replicate it
sometimes I do Adi I don't know I've got
there like I don't know what I'm doing
because it's the moment John's aliens
die you can't rip it and that's what
it's interesting about life that's what
I find interesting about documentaries
because you go that person the next day
be in the same situation and can't say
that in that way you know because in
that moment they felt like that and so
that's my it's that they they kind of
give they trust you it's where you trust
and they trust you to kind of to trust
your instincts and go in and if I know
they'll be frank and then you can
actually have a conversation and in it
they know you're coming from a good
place where you and you're trying to
build something so yeah in terms of kind
of building time Barry says you have in
a way in become the master of accents
you how do you work with kind of you
know getting the right vernacular and
adopting higher so so it seems authentic
so you're not thinking about it as
you're doing it you know kind of you've
mentioned with Steve McQueen widows but
with Black Panther with get out you know
it's so authentic and there's a level of
you know not even seeing you Daniel I'm
seeing you know Chris I'm seeing what
car but I'm seeing that person because
their voice is so natural how do you get
into that mostly fear I have a person
who I know is from there and go if they
watch it they will cuss me out
so I go alright cool that's why I need
to wake up and do what this work like
it's got to be an emotional reason just
an order like all this kind of like
technique that it's like why like what
short like wasn't way in it like so that
that guy is gonna be on what's a gun in
me and so yeah and I just I just drill
it like every morning it's just an it's
an hour's game like I'll just listen
I'll have I'll find a person who is that
person who I think is similar and I just
listen to them instead of listening to a
podcast I just listen to them and so you
you work on it like in a background so
because you don't want that accent and
acting or two different disciplines just
and so you like I could do in it to put
you wanna you can't think about accent
when you're doing your job it's you
can't it's just it helps you to do your
job saying it makes the character more
believable within the world that you're
in but you're still having to express an
emotion or carry some sort of story be
so idea that I just kind of I kind of
just drill it every morning and every
night and then usually after work with
someone like an accent culture or some
sort to kind of like to just to fail to
fail to kind of go that sounds dodgy and
then I record it then I'll listen to
that back and then I got all that sounds
dodgy I'm harsher much like that sounds
bloody when I say it like that
well I like a wide as it's on dodgy
didn't and I speak to the woman again or
the man again I'll go this is this and
it's just you it's a process you know
and then but it's for me it's about who
is that person as opposed to what does
that person sound like because then it's
like because accent isn't just how you
start it's how you carry yourself it's
how you like your your thinking your
like attitude a lot of time its attitude
if I've come and do an American accent
like this I can't do it because this is
quite London how I am Joe so like you
just have to find an adopter as a
general or a kind of person within that
world that's kind of like the generic
person you have to find an identity
within that culture what sorry I
interrupt did you stay in that world in
between takes then yeah I stay in it and
it's really helpful when others stay in
it as well because then you could just
talk in
and people gonna think you're weird for
two days what's up your own r-spec but
then it's just like you mean there when
it comes out you you just have to do
your job you mean so it's like yeah I
just stay in it a lot a lot of times if
I'm by myself in the in the area like I
stay in it when I'm going shopping and
stuff like that so I was there a lot of
time they'll throw words at you and then
you have to just say it you're like i'ma
run Sicario don't they through a word I
mean I know what it is like but so I
just made sure that like anything that
comes my way I can I am more because
when you weren't sure scared of it it
shows up in a tape with Elio staying in
character there is a very definite
physicality to the way he is and the way
that you present him did it help that
you can added over you stayed in the
village where the film was made for a
number of weeks and kind of surrounded
yourself in that environment
did that help and did you kind of stay
yeah absolutely I don't think I was
aware of how much that helped until I
jumped into another project but I mean I
was there a month and a half early we
shot on one camera we shot on one lens
so they weren't switching the camera
positions all the time and switching the
lens and Luca our director his company's
called frenzy and all the members of
production and worked on his other
movies so I had this impression I was
like stepping into a like an Andy Warhol
like factory or something and a great
way like in a in a I felt very position
to succeed you know and and and then
when I jumped into the next thing I did
which was we shot on a stage in LA and
you're working in a studio and you're
opening doors and our real doors and
that's you know we there's a there's a
bit I like and call me by her name or
Elio and Oliver are gonna make love for
the first time and it's kind of awkward
and they don't they're kind of dancing
around it and the door starts shutting
slowly and it slams and that's just a
trade of the house and a beautiful gift
of the villa gave us that day in such a
way that if you weren't shooting on the
actual location it would be more sterile
and sanitized so I like the immersion of
it but I
hard to replicate that because like I
said we were there early it was so
specific to the town and also the
beautiful thing about that story there's
it really isn't an antagonist or a plot
twist or a moment that you know
characters have to play something it's a
lot of people just being you try to be
as truthful and real in every scene and
this movie was like okay be as truthful
as you can now go lounge by that pool
over there and like be as truthful as
you can but have this delicious
breakfast right here and so there's yeah
it's a good experience
[Music]
[Music]